deux bouteilles de plastique des
cannettes un feutre et plein de lego
mais c'est surtout les mégots vous
trouvez cela que les gens arrêtent
défilé comme flora les élus du conseil
municipal des jeunes de bois d'arcy
chasser les déchets mal jeter en général
on trouve beaucoup de cigarettes au bord
des trottoirs alors que des fois il ya
des popeye à des poubelles mais juste de
mètres plus loin
donc c'est pas compliqué de juste avoir
de s'égarer dans la main et de la jeter
de mètres plus loin au lieu de l'acheter
au bord des trottoirs
ce jour là ils sont 20 à avoir enfilé
gants et mentaux dans le quartier du
vieux bourg nettoyons notre ville a été
lancé il y a 6 ont même s'il ya une
nette amélioration par rapport à
certains à certaines années il ya certes
un certain endroit qui sont plus sales
que d'autres donc ils se rendent
vraiment compte de l'incivilité des de
certaines personnes dans leur ville et
ça les touche particulièrement
après deux heures d'activité ils ont
rempli une vingtaine de sacs poubelles
qu'ils ont aussi trier le conseil des
jeunes veut aller plus loin il
travaillait la mise en place d'une
charte écocitoyenne avec les écoles de
la ville